[Music]
thanks for coming to our little
celebration the other day I appreciated
that man that was the highlight of my
year and David McClain the Geographic
photographer who you met he was great he
was blown away he talked about it for
two days you know he comes from rural
Maine and a son b-vector didn't to the
rich rural world of sublime hypnocil is
well I mean I don't know about that but
I mean I'm I was fascinated by his story
I mean I can't imagine first of all the
path towards becoming a National
Geographic photographer I mean you got
to be the dude right I mean that is like
the cream of the crop when it comes to
nature and culture photography you know
there's got to be an amazing story there
and I would imagine he's like he's sort
of following you around now he while he
traveled with you obviously but now he's
still kind of documenting what you're
doing well we're doing a book together
on the recipes if you want to know what
a hundred year old ate to live to a
hundred you have to know what they ate
their whole life so we're trying to get
recipes that are pre 1970 because after
1970 the American food culture hit these
Blue Zones like hurricane Irma and just
destroyed it's destroying him and places
are becoming rife with diabetes and
cancer and the same things that
Americans are suffering so we try
together were we're capturing not only
the recipes but the images so that the
resulting book is going to look like a
hybrid between a cookbook and a National
Geographic art that's pretty cool and
did you work with him on all the Blue
Zones stuff like dating back yes David
shot the first Blue Zones cover story in
2005 and he and I we were just hardcore
explorers for about almost a decade
before that before we worked our way up
to National Geographic we biked across
China together and we did these quests
unravel the mysteries of the collapse of
the ancient Maya civilization and then
we really kind
you know like a band has to practice for
10,000 hours
good we practice for a decade 10 years
before we got good enough and now you
have your groove yeah and he's doing his
thing and I'm doing mine but I hired him
to come back to do things and he's so
hard he's almost impossible just to get
him and my past with him gives me access
lured him back in yeah yeah we have fun
you know we don't we don't we don't
crush it we don't work 16 hours a day
like we used to we knock off at happy
hour right yeah good man well you have a
hot you have a you have a good quality
of life man I you're you're you're
walking the talk like you're actually
living the principles that you've
learned as a result of this crazy
journey that you've been on and it's
nice to see ya thank you you're right
it's a it's you immerse yourself in
these places and you can't help but be
influenced and it's somehow bettered by
them mm-hmm
well the last time we sat down and did
this he was like 3 years ago it was a
while ago least two years ago years ago
I think um there's a lot of new
listeners since then and everybody
should go back and and I don't know
episode number it was but I'll put a
link up into the show notes to the first
time that we did the podcast but it
might be worth just kind of at least you
know establishing you know who you are
and the work that you've done with
respect to the Blue Zones to create a
little context for you know the
happiness stuff that we're gonna get
into yes so my I've been lifelong
Explorer I set three World Records for
biking Alaska Argentina around the world
and across Africa it's been eight years
of my life and then the series of
expeditions that sought to unravel
ancient mysteries and and then on an
assignment for National Geographic and
funding from the National Institutes on
Aging about now I'm 14 years ago we set
out to reverse-engineer longevity so
instead of relying on petri dish studies
or university epidemiology studies we
work with demographers whose expertise
is finding geographic areas where people
have verifiably the longest and once you
find these populations and what that
really means is they're avoiding the
diseases that are killing us hard
disease cancer diabetes dementia chronic
diseases now and then using established
methodologies we reverse engineered the
longevity what these people do to make
it to 100 and we found common
denominators in all five of these Blue
Zones longevity hotspots and the
resulting articles and books and and now
we have entire cities in America
emulating these blue zones and that's
been a big focus and passion of mine for
yeah because I think it's one thing to
kind of I mean first of all you're not
just going and interviewing a few people
like you really did apply like the
scientific method to population studies
and you have this like you know well
honed well established a set of criteria
by which to evaluate all of these
parameters to arrive at the conclusions
that you did and and it and it revealed
these certain truths and commonalities
amongst these cultures and it's one
thing to kind of understand that and
it's another thing to try to figure out
okay well what do we do with this how
are we gonna apply this to better our
own lives and what's really great and
cool about your work is that that's what
you've done you've created this program
where you go to these cities and you
basically like it but at the highest
levels of government and planning right
like you're meeting with people and
trying to configure a way to literally
and systemically change urban planning
and the sort of allocation of dollars to
funnel in the right direction to promote
these habits that are conducive to
longevity and optimal health so tell me
a little bit about that you were in
Kauai from Instagram it looked like you
spend some time in Hawaii
yes that's the most recent one that you
worked on the well right now we have
blue the BlueCross BlueShield hawaii has
hired us to Blue Zone the Big Island of
Hawaii much of Malwa Big Island yeah so
and much of much of Oahu but just to go
back to your earlier comment I want to
make a point the the the way most people
would cover longevity or centenarians as
they find a centenarian and they ask the
centenarian what they ate and how they
slept and what their habits and you know
you find
these kind of silly articles about the
hundred-year-old who ate three eggs a
day and smoked cigars and drink liquor
and had a six year old everybody loves
those stories yeah but that they they're
they're hugely misleading because a
centenarian no more knows how he or she
got to live to 100 than a tall man knows
how he got how he got to be tall the
right way to do it is you have to find a
population that has achieved either
highest centenarian rate highest life
expectancy or lowest rate of middle-aged
mortality once you identify the
population then you can find out what
this whole group of people do because
they're you know about 20% of how long
you live is dictated by your genes the
other 80% is lifestyle and environment
so if you find a centenarian and might
just be because he or she won the
genetic lottery and they can abuse their
body for a hundred years and still make
it to 105 but that doesn't mean they
have any useful lessons for us if you
want useful lessons you have to find
whole verified population and
reverse-engineer and the big aha rich
the big epiphany after almost a decade
was places where people are making it to
a hundred and still water skiing or
standing on their head or doing karate
it's not because they tried it's not
because at age 50 they got on a special
diet or started taking a supplement or
started running marathons in all cases
longevity happened to these people
it was a residue of the right
environment an environment that nudges
them into doing the right things all day
long and with that insight we went about
creating a program that would help
entire American cities live longer not
by trying to convince 800,000 people to
change their habits and eat their
veggies and get their exercise but
rather by shaping their environment so
they're mindlessly and will
Lent lessly nudged into doing the right
thing rather than the wrong thing right
so healthy lifestyle is a byproduct of
the environment environment not not a
byproduct of conscious decision making
it's an extrapolation of what's
available to you at arms link it's the
convenient choice as opposed to the more
difficult or more expensive choice
that's right so you you have Herculean
discipline I mean you're these ultra
marathons that you do that inspire so
many people they are for sure a positive
force but most people if you look at the
research who start off and start running
marathons they're no running no longer
running marathons in two years people
who start off on a diet no matter how
much resolve they have on day one ninety
percent of them are off of them on by
the seventh what are you before we move
off this point like what do you make of
that like what do you extract from that
simple fact that people have trouble
sort of staying on point our our minds
are hardwired for novelty so we we crave
new things our attention can last only
so long discipline is a muscle and
muscles fatigue and eventually you kind
of revert to the mean of what you're
doing or the baseline of what you're
doing so if you want that baseline if
you want people to perform better eat
better move better socialize better have
more purpose you need to raise the
baseline you need to optimize the
environment which is exactly what we set
out to do and so when you go into these
cities or you go to Hawaii what are the
talking points like how do you you know
shift that paradigm first of all the
cities have to want us so instead of a
riot we don't have a sales force cities
come to us all the time and we say if
you like if you're sick of seeing 70% of
your population overweight and unhealthy
we have a solution but you have to prove
to us a you're ready for it sort of
politically be you have to show us your
leadership works well together and see
we have to collectively figure out a way
to pay for because the only way you make
these changes is if I can get put a full
time staff in there for
three or five years it I would imagine
it requires the political will to invest
in the long-term right because it's not
about the next election cycle with
whoever is mayor or governor or
what-have-you like they have to think
what is in the best interest of our
electorate of our population and it's a
solution that's not going to manifest
itself overnight or in the next two
years perhaps even it's going to require
you know probably a large investment of
capital and a long-term vision to you
know raise that mean for everybody so
that eventually everybody prospers but
it's not like the it's not like a cliff
Beatty kind of no immediate solution to
what ails a particular urban environment
it's focusing on permanent or
semi-permanent changes to the
environment and it also requires the
political will you know America we we
have this obsession with freedom and in
order to be successful we have to come
into a city where they're prepared to
limit our freedoms to do unhealthy
that's the kind of the bottom line I
wouldn't put it that way to them but at
the end of the day we're trying to limit
their access to junk food we're trying
to limit their access to always getting
in cars we're trying to limit the
occasion where they're gonna implode
into their devices so in every city I
have three teams three squads full-time
one squad just works with City Council
to adopt food policy does that favor
fruits and vegetables over junk food
that works with the built environment
city planner to design their their
cities for humans not just cars you can
raise the physical activity levels of
the whole city by 30 percent by just
making parks accessible providing bike
lanes providing bus public
transportation provide means to walk
places the limit sprawl and then lastly
we have an alcohol policy bundle which
brings in the evidence
best practices to limit access to
alcohol uh-huh not not cut it off
altogether the second squad goes to
every restaurant grocery store workplace
in school with a blue zone certification
program which makes those environments
20% healthier and we recognize them and
drive traffic to them and the third
squad works with individuals to help
individuals optimize their home so their
kitchens aren't as accessible to junk
food to optimize their social networks
so they're making three or four new
friends who are plant-based eaters and
who recreative 'ti and then to know
their sense of purpose and put it to
work by volunteering so when you when
you bring all three of those together
you create the perfect storm with enough
intensity three to five years in every
single city we see obesity dropping down
and Happiness going up Wow and so when
these you know three infantry teams you
know paratroop these cities and you know
occupy the territory like how long does
that take like how long do they stay
there what's the you know what is the
kind of arc of that gestation cycle so
what do you think so Fort Worth Texas is
our biggest you know bizarrely enough we
work mostly in very conservative areas
because and I can't explain why but
we've been very successful so in Fort
Worth there are 200 schools there are
about a thousand different restaurants
so our team you know we have a team of
30 people they have to get every one of
those restaurants and schools and
grocery stores and workplace there's
literally going door to door yeah they
make appointments and and they have to
sit down explain why to do this with
policy the way our policy works is we
come in with these we don't tell people
what to do we don't tell city council
you have to do this or you're not going
to be certified Blue Zone but we do show
them a menu with 30 evidence-based
policies that make their city healthier
either from a food point of view or a
built environment point of view we bring
all the leaders together help them
arrive arrive at consensus of what would
be effective
and feasible here and then our team
works with city government to adopt
these policies and implement them and
that usually takes three to five years
but when you get them in there they're
in there forever you know if we get them
to increase the walkability by thirty
percent those sidewalks are there for ya
half a century
so unlike trying to convince somebody to
join a gym or start us you know CrossFit
regimen which is gonna wet run out of
gas in a year this last four decades
uh-huh so is Fort Worth the biggest
success story or just the largest urban
it's the largest the biggest success
story is right here in California the
beach cities of Redondo normal sand
Manhattan Beach and in the five years we
worked out we just got the Gallup data
the average BMI of the entire city
dropped by 14% Wow
start saying what does that mean that
means there are nineteen hundred fewer
obese people there than when we started
the obesity rate among children has
dropped by about 50 percent and they've
saved 5060 million dollars and projected
healthcare costs because of lower rates
of diabetes and obesity so it was a
hugely great
so so give me an example of something
that changed there like we're there were
there like bike paths that were built or
where they're you know menu items
changed at restaurants or school lunch
yeah altered or how did that you know
play out so we were instrumental in
putting in about two hundred twenty more
miles of bike paths and you know la is a
place where people are obsessed with
their cars
we were instrumental in connecting
Paulo's Verde with the rest of the beach
cities so you can bicycle all the way up
and down
we're instrumental in getting an active
living policy in place so that now every
new street the streets are rebuilt every
five to seven years has to be planned
with the bike lane trees and a sidewalk
in mind so that starts to shift the
paradigm from the car to people being on
their feet when we started absolutely no
kids walk to school now about 40% of all
school elementary schools have these
walking school buses where they walk
than adults so the kids and the adults
are walking school lunches have changed
we prioritize vegetables so when you go
through the lunch line the first food
kid sees our vegetables they're more
likely to take it and eat it then when
you put it at the end right that's a
huge win I would I would think tackling
the school lunch thing is is tough you
know there's a lot of money involved in
contracts that you know are very rich
for the people that benefit from landing
them the food providers
well well here's the great untold secret
the USDA provides most of the funding
for school lunches most public schools
cannot afford school lunches without
USDA money if you take the USDA money
you have to buy USDA foods which ends up
being meats and cheeses and milks I mean
there's some you know vegetables but but
there's kind of a catch-22 I know
there's also not money to hire cooks
like before the Reagan era the the only
money available for schools are very low
paid employees and the in the kitchen
who just warm things so you get a lot of
like pizza pockets and pizzas and crap
but actually there's one policy that is
even more powerful when it comes to what
your kids eat at school and that's
whether or not kids can eat in hallways
in classrooms so spending zero money if
a school says no eating in classrooms
and hallways the BMI of that school
drops by about 11% over the course huh
you're saying and that's just because if
they can't eat in classrooms and
hallways that are not eating chip and
sodas and candy and and getting rid of
vending machines is that part of it too
that's part of it so once again we to be
a blue zone certified school we come
with a menu and it has 20 different
things it's about 20 things a school can
do to to improve the health environment
at school other things are you know
there's often snack carts after school
you can make sure there's only healthy
choices on that snack cart
in vending machines not necessarily
taking them out but only including water
in them and healthy snacks in Redondo
Beach they created a thousand-foot
radius around the school where no junk
food vendors could come after school Wow
we've even had Spencer Iowa one of our
blue zone cities its city calls very
conservative place they had the courage
to say no to a convenience store that
was about to open up very close to the
school because that convenience store
opens up what are the kids eating after
school if they skipping lunch and
running across the street to the
convenience store what are they eating
so by taking that by zoning it so they
don't have access to that to that
convenience store
you just improve the eating environment
you know kids have to stain either
lunchroom it's so interesting that it's
these conservative communities because
you would think these are the keys are
the these are the government bodies that
are saying you know we don't we want
less regulation and we don't want you
you know government telling us what to
do yeah all of that so that's
fascinating but you have that juxtaposed
with people with for the most part you
know with with a great family boundaries
they care about their kids and they care
about their community doesn't matter if
you're left or right but but sometimes
III sense in our considerate of
communities there's a stronger sense of
civic we're gonna get this done yeah I
think that's probably right
so yeah it surprised me I thought this
was going to be a project for the san
francisco's of the country but it turned
out it's the Fort Worth and the Iowas
and the end the Naples for it all very
conservative places and it's it is going
gangbusters it's got to be incredibly
gratifying to translate you know this
work that you've done into a very real
context where it's having a macro effect
in a incredibly substantial way on vast
numbers of people it's not just like I
did this research I found these
conclusions I wrote a book about it and
like here you go like you're actually
shifting not only the way people think
about these things but their behavior in
the way that it's influenced by the very
habitats in which they live they're two
very different yes you're right it's
very satisfying the first book the Blue
Zones identified the nine common
denominators and the longest lived
people so that's what you can do to live
to 100 but the how was a very different
animal and I very consciously went about
trying to find how do you get people to
adopt these habits long enough so they
can avoid a chronic disease so you have
to not do the wrong thing mm-hmm for
long enough to live a long time right so
that it's more focused on avoiding the
wrong thing then yeah the right thing it
really is cuz that's what I mean that
that's what what kills us at the end I
think but it was a completely different
science and National Geographic bless
its heart my my home they gave me a
grant to look at communities that were
unhealthy and got healthier so not Blue
Zones as it were but just places 1972
North Korea Finland had the highest rate
of cardiovascular disease in the world
and miraculously and this is the only
place in the world they were able to
reduce the incidence of cardiovascular
mortality in men by 80%
stomach cancer by about 60% and it's and
they held it for 30 years I think we
talked about this last time but I remind
me what they were doing before and what
the change was this was a 140,000 people
who were mostly dairy farmers they fried
their cheese and butter and an
epidemiologist by the name of Pekka
pushka came in and did everything that
most public health people have done for
years they promoted these fun runs and
eat your veggie campaigns and and and
health messaging and he burned through
his entire budget in five years and he
got this idea actually there the mother
ship of what we do they got the idea of
change in the environment and they did
things they realized that people love
their sausage there and they weren't
going to convince 140,000 people not to
sauce ain't gonna happen but they went
to the sausage maker and convinced the
sausage maker to replace 30% of the fat
with mushrooms and to take up 30% of the
sodium and they weren't you people in
North Carolina eating vegetable fruits
because they were expensive and they
weren't accessible and Pekka pushka
convinced dairy farmers to take part of
their land and grow berries and then
created a market for those berries so
that all of a sudden berries were
accessible and you could buy him
year-round so people started eating more
of them so it was a change in the
environment right interesting that's
super cool man
so in the course of doing you know
rolling up your sleeves and doing this
Blue Zones work and traveling the world
and meeting with all of these people you
know one aspect of this Blue Zones
equation is life satisfaction and packed
into that is happiness and the idea that
you know happiness and health are not
mutually exclusive ideas that these are
very much you know integrated they're
they're part and parcel of each other so
in many ways I sort of think about this
new you know sort of tangent that you're
on not tangent but this you know
companion Kamiya extrapolation of the
work that you've been doing venturing
directly into the world of happiness is
really just an extension of work that
you've been doing all along but kind of
more focused in one particular arena is
that is that accurate yes so it first of
all if it's not worth 100 if you're
miserable so you learn right knock on
the door if you are according to your
work at least exactly but also it turns
out in America if you're if you're in
the top quintile the happiest people you
live about eight years longer than you
if you're in the lowest quintile so so
working on getting happier is almost as
powerful as dropping a smoking habit
when it comes to life expectancy and I
sort of developed I think this way of
identifying the longest the people who
do it the best evidence-based and then
reverse engineering it so with blue
zones of first blue zones it was long
stood people and now with happiness
we're fine
we we found this statistically happiest
people in the world and then
reverse-engineered what exactly they did
to get so happy right so before we dig
into that let's define happiness and
then secondarily perhaps you can talk a
little bit about how you came up with a
quantitative method for for evaluating
this on a community-wide basis so
happiness is an academically speaking a
meaningless term it and I think I reveal
this in the book in a way you probably
haven't seen before but but sort of
simplified happiness is an amalgam of
how you experience your life day to day
how much joy you get out of every day
number two how you evaluate your life
what you think of yourself how proud you
are of what you've done and how you've
lived up to the expectations around you
and number three purpose feeling like
you're living out your values and it
turns out that all three of those facets
of happiness are measurable they're
measurable on an international level and
indeed Gallup and the world database of
happiness measure all three of those
kinds of happiness in a hundred and
fifty-one countries worldwide and I was
able to connect with them thanks to
National Geographic and get their
statistician x' to tell me where are
people experiencing those three kinds of
happiness at the highest level and then
go there and try to explain what they're
doing to achieve those kinds of
happiness right and and in so doing and
there's some overlap with the Blue Zones
right but there are also distinct
regions that live sort of askew from the
from the Blue Zones that you initially
established well they're not the exact
same place but the original Blue Zones
areas of longevity they are within the
top 10 percent of the happiest places in
the world there are places that are
slightly happier but they're also very
healthy mm-hmm so Singapore for example
it's a happiest place in Asia as
measured by life satisfaction and also
absence of worry and stress
but they also have the second highest
life expectancy in the world so to the
point you made at the very beginning
here that longevity happiness go ahead
and here they're closely related and the
other thing that I think is interesting
about evaluating happiness is that once
again not a surprise to you I'm sure you
find that the happiest people live in
places where the environment is
conducive to the factors that contribute
to that happiness that's the bottom line
right it's just like there's all these
studies that show that the harder you
work to be happy the less happy you are
and in a sense what we're all doing yeah
it's like Sisyphus you know rolling the
boulder up the hill and only to find it
back down at the bottom the next day
when you wake up the so positive
psychology Marty Seligman and Sonja
Lyubomirsky or who lives right around
here
they're great scientists and they have
identified the techniques we can all do
to get a little bit happier and you've
heard about them savoring gratitude
meditation they all kind of work but
they all kind of fall in the same
category as diets is they require a
conscious behavior modification you have
to remember to do something every day
you find time in your schedule and have
the discipline and presence of mind to
do it and that there is no evidence to
show that any of those things work in
the long term because we in order for
them to work you have to do them they
wear out but there are dozens of things
you can do to changing your environment
to make it more likely you'll be happy
so the blue zones of happiness book is
more about what you can do to design
your surroundings to stack the deck in
favor of happiness and and I think well
we should unpack that and get into it
but let's let's run through a couple of
the case studies because I think it's
super interesting when you talk about
you know what it's like in Singapore and
why they're happy for example you know
based on the way that
you know the way that the city was was
conceptualized and planned in terms of
how people live and the tax structure
and how they you know think about career
etc yes so you know that we love
democracy but often the problem with
democracy it amounts to a pooling of
ignorance and especially if people
aren't getting the right education and
that like it's almost impossible for an
American politician to make a long-term
plan that that extends beyond his or her
own tenure in Singapore they were
blessed I would argue with a great
leader by the name of Lee Kuan Yew a
Cambridge educated lawyer who came in in
1965 under a difficult time there was
wars with the Communists brewing at the
time but he was very smart he was imbued
with Confucian values of harmony of
honoring older people of embracing
security as and he was a big gardener as
well and he was also a the massive
gardens oh yeah yeah yeah it's it's the
second most densely populated place on
earth it's 45 miles long home to five
million people and there's greenery all
around you beautiful parks very smart
use of the land but he went about taking
a data backed approach to building a
country that enabled these people to
live out their values Confucian values
in this not judeo-christians which
Americans tend to embrace but these more
Asian values and he's done a spectacular
job at at the the their economy has
doubled 13 times since 1965 one of the
highest GDP s in the world highest life
expectancies and and highest rates of
life satisfaction in all of Asia
yeah I thought it was really fascinating
how you describe how they promote
diversity in in the way that people
habitate cohabitate because a lot most
people live in these giant
apartment buildings right and how the
demographics of those buildings reflect
the demographic of the city at hole
right so there's no you know this is
where all the Jewish people live and
this is where all the Puerto Ricans live
or what-have-you right everything is
integrated right so Lee Kuan Yew
inherited a diverse population they're
made up of han chinese the malay from
malaysian ethnicity and indians that's
most of who lived there speak completely
different languages very different
cultures often at odds with each other
and he knew he was going to have a
sieving stew of of conflict and he did a
few very smart things first of all he
made English the lingua franca so none
of the other three US cities got to use
their language they brought in this
fourth language every school reflects
the ethnicity of the country and there
are Singapore which is actually a
country it's sort of a city state as a
has these subdivisions so to speak of
about 250,000 people live in these
high-rise and every high-rise reflects
that contains Malay Indian and and
Chinese and you you go downstairs in the
food courts and they're all just these
wonderful bazaars of these ethnic foods
that reflect that people live there or
so right and and talk about the tax
structure and is it is Singapore one of
the places where the tax structure is is
implicated and kind of infusing the
culture with a higher happiness quotient
yes it's a couple other places so that
they're brilliant Singapore say so first
of all you see a correlation between
places who take care of their their
elders and Happiness and Singapore
spends more on its elders than any place
else in Asia and one of the things they
very cleverly do if you if you live
within a hundred meters of your aging
parent you get a tax break that's
because Lee Kuan Yew knows that given
their values of elder veneration you're
going to take care of your parents that
they live nearby
and you're incentivized to do so yes
it's just such a foreign concept from
our cultural idea of warehousing our our
parents in a retirement home the other
very clever thing they do if if you want
to consume imported luxuries like Swiss
chocolate or electronics or jewelry
there's a very high value-added tax so
it disincentivizes a consumption
consumption by the way the happiness
value of it wears out very quickly but
the auntie no matter who you are no
matter where you live in the world in
order to have happiness you need food
shelter health or health care some
education some mobility and you have to
be able to treat yourself once in a
while so after that the effect of money
on happiness starts to wear out very
quickly well Lee Kuan Yew is made it
very easy for everybody to have that
that minimum five or six things for
happiness and no matter if you are
working a food stand or sweep the
streets or clean up public lavatories as
long as you make an effort to work
you're gonna make enough money to cover
your needs those five or six things they
call it instead of a welfare it's called
work fair mm-hmm so they'll top-up your
wages so you get this minimum right and
same thing in Denmark right Denmark you
just it's everybody right no matter what
right you're like the lawyer in the post
you can sit College eat Doritos and
watch reruns of two beaver and you'll
get that money which is the antithesis
of capitalism and yet here we have a
very happy population of people and it's
it's uh it's amazing because we all kind
of intellectually know like all right so
if we can meet our needs and we could
pay our bills and we have a health care
then anything beyond that has a you know
a diminishing return in terms of our
happiness quotient right and your your
works used to prove this out yes well
when it comes to money yes but there are
other things she bred I'm talking about
money I'm sorry I'm talking purely about
money yeah and this idea that you know
your that money would be best spent
saving to continue to
alleviate the stress and anxiety that
comes with the insecurity of not having
enough and also to be you know channel
towards experiences right yeah well let
me let me interject an a nuance here
that's important this is from Daniel
Kahneman and Angus Deaton both of whom
won Nobel prizes so they're the ones
that figured out that when it comes to
money and how you experience your life
you don't get any more gratification or
happiness after about seventy five
thousand dollars a year but when it
comes to how you evaluate your life life
satisfaction the more money you make the
higher satisfaction is I saw actually
billionaires they evaluate their lives
better than millionaires so it just
depends what you're after yeah I guess
it was oh it's always been confusing to
me that you know after a certain point a
millionaire and a billionaire still you
know propelling themselves selves
forward to accumulate more and more and
more so obviously they are getting that
kind of satisfaction out of it although
it's not changing the day to day quality
of their life in fact it may be
inhibiting it exactly they would maybe
they would say otherwise but but it's a
little bit like and I'm hoping this book
kind of illuminates this that you know
people want to know the secret to
happiness and I can't tell you the
secret of happiness unless I know who
you are so there are people for whom
measuring themselves against other
people is a prime value mm-hmm and for
them working to go from a million
dollars to a billion dollars is a good
investment for them most of us I think
you and me included we're more
interested in really savoring our lives
being present and experience it from day
to day you know it's important for us to
to feel proud of what we do and and
achieve financial security but after
that we're not gonna kill ourselves but
there are people who are there are
people that's that's the name of the
game and they're gonna they're gonna
they can only be happy if if they
achieve some fanatic level of success
right alright so we talked about
Singapore we touched on ten
mark we have the Nicoya Peninsula once
again front and center right Costa Rica
whoa it's actually Cartago Costa Rica so
the the Blue Zone area longevity is is
Nicoya which is on the coast the
happiest place actually is in the center
of Costa Rica in the Central Valley
place called Kota toggle and similar to
Singapore it kind of started from the
top down because the powers-that-be
came from education backgrounds right
there were teachers yes
so I argue that if you have a happy
place in the world it does never happens
by chance it's not just because they
have a happy culture but that's you look
at Costa Rica very happy place
you look North in Nicaragua it's a
basket case in South and Panama it's a
basket case and they're both you know
Latin American cultures but for some
reason Costa Rica's by orders of
magnitude happier than Nicaragua to the
north and if whether you look at the
Denmark Singapore Costa Rica or I also
profile Boulder Colorado all of these
happy places have their roots in four or
so policies enlightened leaders between
50 and 150 years ago shifted away from
kind of blind economic growth and
channeled resources into educating kids
and I'm not talking about phd's I'm
talking about getting 98 or 99 percent
of children literate educating women
interestingly Costa Rica and Denmark
were two of the first countries on earth
to educate the daughters of peasants not
the sons the daughters and why is that
important because daughters grow up to
be mothers and when you have an educated
mother she tends to have fewer children
she tends to take care of her children
better but tends to make sure they get a
better education they grow up healthier
smarter they get better jobs they're
more productive they're healthier they
make better voting decisions and it
creates this upward ratcheting of
happiness also the emphasis in all happy
places there's a big investment in
public health and this is vastly
different than the national conversation
we're having now between Obamacare and
whatever the Republicans are are
promoting you know in this country which
is unclear right now
yeah but regardless of which one wins
it's the same flawed economic system we
we incent for sickness nobody makes
money in this country and health and
unless you get sick
pharmaceutical companies make money when
you get a prescription hospitals make
money when you rent a bus bed and
doctors get paid for procedures and
insurance companies and insurance
companies in between you know doctors
are great people but they get too paid
the same at whether they cure they cure
you or they kill you in places where
people are happy the investment is put
way upstream to help make sure you don't
get sick in the first place so Costa
Rica for example I think is the best
health care system in the world every
man woman and child this is a very poor
country by the way has the right of one
visit a year from a health professional
somebody's gonna come knock on your door
spend 30 minutes with you no matter who
you are take your blood pressure check
you for diabetes check you for
depression and they're gonna go in your
backyard look for standing water so that
Zika doesn't breathe they're gonna go in
your refrigerator and and give you some
advice about what should be in there and
what should not be in there and they're
catching diseases like diabetes and
heart disease decades before it's a
three alarm fire and it's that health
was we started off this conversation
that health and happiness they go hand
in hand and and Costa Rica has about
half the rate of mortality middle-aged
mortality that Americans do two and a
half time better chance of reaching a
healthy age 92 and they spend one
fifteenth the amount we do on health
care right so there's a lesson there
that we should be listening to I know
well the the lessons that can be
extrapolated from these various cultures
are innumerable right and I think he
goes it goes back to political will
like what are the systemic changes that
would have to occur in a country like
the United States in order to begin
implementing some of these policy shifts
that are obviously you know so
positively beneficial so as part of this
Geographic project we hired the top 10
economists and happiness experts in the
world and did this Delphi procedure
which is a scientific consensus to get
the best ideas together and to rank them
for effectiveness and for feasibility
and we identified the 10 things that
Americans or leaders anywhere should be
doing if the if they really want a
happier nation and I think it starts
with the evidence base knowing what
works and what doesn't work
I mean we're what we think brings us
happiness both at a population level on
an individual level is misguided and
often completely wrong
for example growing group GDP and that
tends to be the yardstick of success of
a country that only works with poor
countries after you get to the GDP of
all Portugal trying to raise GDP more
has very little effect on how happy you
are but about one-sixth of any
population in the world is suffering
from some sort of mental illness anxiety
or depression those are the big ones
about 16 percent of population they
drive about 50% of the unhappiness in
any country and it turns out you can
resolve about 50 percent of the anxiety
and depression cases with just 12
sessions of cognitive behavioral therapy
so if America this is gonna sound weird
but this is what the evidence says if
America wanted to become significantly
happier the best investment we can make
is make sure that everybody who's
depressed and suffering from anxiety in
this country got cognitive behavioral
therapy and by the way those people with
these mental illnesses they drive about
50% of the use of social services they
drive about 50% of the crime 50% of the
absenteeism and 50% of the
hospitalization I would imagine
pharmaceutical dependence as well and
you know yes translating from that
you know drug addiction which obviously
leads back to crime and the
privatizations of our prisons and the
lack of investment or interest in really
developing you know treatment for these
conditions we're just warehousing these
people and we're we're just perpetrating
a vicious cycle that leads to more crime
and more disenfranchisement and more
addiction and it just goes on and on and
on but yet we fail to see that so if you
have diabetes in this country there's a
nearly a 100% chance you'll be you'll be
treated for you anybody get treatment
for diabetes in this country and there's
a huge pharmaceutical companies make a
ton of money off of diabetes drugs if
you have depression or anxiety there's
only about a 15% chance you'd be treated
in this country largely goes untreated
because you know there's no big sort of
cognitive behavioral therapy lobby
that's making sure that we're getting
that kind of treatment here it's not
this doesn't have the economic
underpinnings that that a pharmaceutical
approach does yeah although there's a
lot of you know prescription medications
getting doled out to deal with these
things but perhaps not enough focus on
the cognitive therapy aspect of it yes
and we know cognitive theory behavioral
therapy works if the cognitive
behavioral therapy were a drug it'd be a
blockbuster drug and it is 50 percent
successful there's good research behind
that wow that's amazing
tolerance is a big thing too right in
these communities yeah at an
international level yeah essentially you
want to live in a place where you can
feel free to live out the life that's
right for you so if you're a woman you
want to be you have the same rights as a
man if you're old if you're gay if
you're transgender
so Denmark is one of the most tolerant
places in the world so essentially that
the this these findings start with a a
statistical basis so these international
surveys ask you how happy you are in an
up variety of different ways
and then they ask you 60 or 70 out of
the questions about how you live your
life how much money you make are you
married your religiosity do you are you
doing new and interesting things every
day do you feel healthy do you do you
trust your neighbors do you feel like
you can live out your values etc and
then there's a statistical process known
as regression analysis where you can
find out what correlates with happiness
or what what what goes hand-in-hand with
happiness and the big six are trust
can I trust my neighbor tolerance can
live on my values do I have really good
social connections healthy life
expectancy GDP is one of them and
freedom but not so much freedom to do
anything but freedom once again to to do
the work that's right for you those are
the the big core let's to happen there's
no matter where you live and from that
you kind of drill down
tell me if I'm misinterpreting this but
you drill down on these kind of three
core ideas pleasure purpose and pride as
kind of cofactors in your own analysis
of your personal happiness quotient is
that well all of these surveys measure
life satisfaction which is essentially
pride positive effect which is how
you've experienced in your life in the
last 24 hours
I call that pleasure and then purpose go
ahead and do new and interesting things
every day
so those three P's are actually measured
I kind of simplified the epidemic terms
but we know statistically speaking were
those three types of happiness excel the
most and where does the United States
fall on this spectrum of happiness you
know we get like a B I mean given our
GDP given how wealthy water we should be
doing a lot better we're about 27th in
the country in the world and is there
any one of these factors where we're
well below what would be considered
average yes where's our where's our weak
spot so there's vast variation
in its it's not really fair to talk
about the US because in the in the
southeastern the Appalachia the Rust
Belt those places are very unhappy on
all three but then you look to places
like Boulder Colorado San Luis Obispo
Ogden Utah Minneapolis Minnesota
Portland those places are world-class
when it comes to all three so it depends
where you are in the United States and
holder is one of the ones that you
selected as the top right among the top
in the world so Dan winters over at the
senior scientists at Gallup and I worked
on an index that we tried to find the 15
when he calls call bell measures of what
really is happiness what are the what
are the what's the componentry of
happiness and we created a special index
and applied it to 171 cities in America
and Boulder came off the top Santa Cruz
was very high up there Santa Barbara San
Luis Obispo Charleston North Carolina
was actually pretty high Naples Ford and
these communities what are the main
things that they share in common beyond
we we've already talked about their
walkable and bikable very high correlate
there is a healthy food environment
there was enlightened leadership that
shifted the focus from just economic
development to quality of life the often
building and development and improv and
and progress are mutually exclusive
pursuits to creating a high quality of
life and most of these happy cities have
said we're putting okay we have enough
we've developed enough now let's
preserve our natural environment and
let's focus on building quality of life
from both a policy point of view and a
built environment point of view bikes
are a big part of this whole thing bikes
and walking right you look at the Walk
Score which you can go online and plug
in your zip code and it will tell you
the walks our Walk Score is probably the
biggest predictor of how happy your city
is Copenhagen's most likeable
city on earth it's also the happiest
that's cool we don't live we don't I
don't live in a walkable place well
think about cars so if you live on a
street where cars are zipping by at 50
miles an hour number one you have that
noise which creates stress there's
danger there is no there's pollution and
we know now that car pollution is
associated with diabetes dementia and
even kidney failure you can't you don't
want you can't walk for you can't move
and get exercise because you know you're
at the bottom of the food transportation
food chain when you're on your feet when
you live in a place that's bikable it's
quiet you run into people it's very easy
to get to places to shop and places to
worship and socialize it's it's if
America could see clearly the best
investment I think at an urban level
would be making our cities more water
I'm like hence you're now living in
Santa Barbara mama didn't raise no fool
I now live in this region of the world
without a car which is not easy to do
although uber house I know I don't know
Carla and when I when I install in Santa
Barbara I never get in a car I mean I
come back and forth to the airport or
something that car but I get on my bike
yeah go everywhere so I took the Blue
Zones ten minute happiness quiz on your
web true happiness test true happiness
test yes and I proudly scored an A+
which I'm very happy about only despite
the fact that there's one question about
how much time do you spend in the car
and I just slide that slider all the way
from right now I was like this is gonna
up my score but I was like yeah is
definitely gonna put me down in the
b-minus fast driving around all the time
but I think I over I compensated for it
with I think in large part like a sense
of purposefulness like the e key guy
that you talked about with Blue Zones I
think is very high in my life and and
you know diet and exercise obviously
movement
and community like I make a practice of
making sure that I take time for friends
which isn't always easy and isn't my
default thing but when I do my life is
happier and better yeah I had the
privilege last Saturday to join you with
your in your community and you're very
generous and you're also a curator be
one of these connectors and one of the
more dependable ways to get happier no
matter what kind of happiness is improve
your social equity your social
connections and you are a master at
putting interesting people together and
sort of being at them at them at the
center of it not as a mimimi I want the
attention but supporting people from the
outside and you're a giver to put it in
Adam grants words well it was a it was a
pleasure and a delight to be able to
host that thing and Greg my business
partner I have to give credit to him
he's the one who kind of you know
orchestrated the whole thing but it was
it was great and I think for me it was
beautiful not just to get all these
people that I loved so much in one room
and so they could meet each other and
all of that but then to take everybody
over to see in q ohm and I know like you
know you probably did you even know who
inked you ready to roll my eyes yeah I
mean you guys you guys were out of there
like a lot of people were like yeah
that's cool I'm here for the party I
don't know about being Q part and I was
like no no you guys you gotta check this
out so I think your your perspective was
common like a lot of people were like
didn't really know what to expect or who
he was and and he was just he was such a
it was kind of a beautiful gift to give
to everyone I realize this is it's he
was so inspiring and you know it's
impossible to not you know sit there and
listen to him and not leave you know
feeling amazing I think he metabolized
the human condition living in 2017 and
helped us we we all feel exactly what he
described but he helped he first of all
he didn't put himself above us we was
among us you know he was talking about
seeing his old therapist at his new
therapist
I know but it's cold nervous in the
waiting room coming out from his new
they're like hey but he helped he helps
he helps us all make sense of this of
this crazy journey we're on yeah he
really does in a very beautiful touched
poetic way Derrick's yeah so I'm glad
you guys came and experienced that it
was cool loved it so let's let's let's
like really distill down these
principles of happiness and and try I
want to get at the heart of like how we
can you know think about this you know
the average person can think about these
things and and and think about how they
can cultivate greater happiness in their
own lives by making some lifestyle
changes and decisions you know perhaps
about the environment that they choose
to surround you know the people in the
actual physical environment in which
they live but you know even beyond that
I know that there are lifestyle you know
things that can be tweaked to help
promote these things even though it's
it's easier to put yourself in the
environment that fosters that but you
know behavioral change I think is still
you know an important part of it is it
not it's it's important if you can
remember to do it and I just essentially
assume that people aren't going to
remember you yeah so so so happiness is
a cake recipe and move to Boulder yeah
kind of that's where I was going
marrying the right person or being with
the right person getting the right work
being healthy feeling like you're giving
back they're all ingredients the most
important ingredient in that cake recipe
is where you live so if you're unhappy
probably the most powerful thing you can
do if you want to get happier is move to
a happier place and we know that
statistically speaking it has the
biggest variance of any variable and you
might say well I can't do that but the
average American moves about ten times
in their adult life so there's ten
opportunities and if you're not if you
can't live to a half of your city you
can live to a happier neighborhood and a
happier neighborhood looks like this it
has a sidewalk out in front of your
house you live on a street where
neighbors have about the same status
level that you do there are trees
there's easy access to parks
I live in Minneapolis there's nobody
lives more than four blocks away from a
park you're close to places to worship
you're close to i'm being able to buy
healthy food those are all elements more
likely if you live on water you're about
five percent more likely to be happy
this Ocean River Lake you the happiest
cities in America tend to be University
towns so that stacks the deck in your
favor when it comes to your house you
want to position your house so that
invites people and the happiest
Americans are socially interacting five
to six hours a day so you want to
position yourself so you're inviting
people in so instead of a back deck a
front porch and that's that those hours
of socialization include home and and
profession and I presume yeah the key is
that you're interacting with someone
with whom you can have a meaningful
conversation and you actually like them
right so your best friend works where
you work yeah or it can just be an okay
friend but it has to transcend talking
smack sports or celebrity or something
you have to be able to say you know I
just had a big fight with my spouse and
you know what does ever happen to you
type of thing so so that's the criteria
it's be meaningful conference and it
could be with your family too or your
neighbors you want you want to make sure
that your bedroom is set up so it's easy
for you to get between seven and a half
and nine hours of sleep so blackout
windows take the electronics out of that
the happiest people are sleeping over
seven and a half hours a night on
average if you're sleeping six hours a
night you're probably thirty percent
less happy than you are mmm so that's a
really big one as well
TVs there's room in our life for TVs and
other screens we did this huge research
project with national Geographics a
hundred thousand respondents and found
that people are concept are most happy
when they're watching between a half
hour and an hour of TV a day so having a
little bit of intellectual repose at the
end of a hard day is okay but if you're
watching more than an hour a day it's
probably at the
Bent's of doing more authentic forms of
happiness like physical activity or
social interacting or volunteering are
there studies on internet use there's
studies on suis also did one on social
media so like Facebook and Twitter and
Instagram the same thing it's about 45
minutes actually people who are not on
social media at all and people using it
about two hours a day are about the same
level report the same level of happiness
the best is about an hour a day which
suggests that they're on it
for a little entertainment maybe to
connect in the real world
but after two hours you see this direct
correspondence of dropping happiness
with more social media use and the least
happy people are on at eight hours a day
right so that's a it's an approximation
of the truth and is there a distinction
obviously community is important is
there a breakdown or a distinction
between those that are actively engaged
in a faith-based community versus people
that are just involved in their civic
community well its religiosity is
measured and it's measured by how often
you show up to church or temple or
mosque and as a rule people who are
religious are slightly happier and
you're especially happier if you live in
a religious part of the country so being
religious in Denmark for example we're
only about 20% of people show up to
church being being a churchgoer doesn't
help your happiness much but if you live
in the Bible Belt you're much more
likely to be happy we are involved in
your community you know in a more
fundamental way I would imagine
volunteers are happier no matter where
you go on the most counterintuitive
thing in the world if you get fired from
your job the best thing to do is go on
volunteer take that focus on off of your
own woes and put it on to something else
get out and network and get out and and
put your your purpose to work elsewhere
so your point about community yes
getting involved with your community is
definitely a secret to happiness and
what about meditation net positive
so medic meditations one of these women
all things so here's the thing with a
meditation I think you have to do it
intensely enough for a while either some
meditation course or sticking out
sticking with it for 10 weeks or doing a
veep asana where you kind of rewire your
brain your meditator and you know you
know how to do it and you can quickly do
it but if you're just gonna meditate in
front of you know before yoga class for
a while it's not going to do you any
good
and meditation likes so many other
positive psychology interventions for
the most part it only works as long as
you're doing it so we tend to do it
episodically and if you do it every day
yes there's good evidence but you know
people don't do it every day
you're like the doctor who's like yeah I
could tell them to eat better but
they're not gonna do it so I'm just
giving them this pill like sending them
on yeah you know you're telling them to
move I mean I I wouldn't I'm like the
doctor who says you tell me better but
knowing they won't do it I'm vytorin in
my house and I'll cheat em teach em how
to make a delicious it Koreans do or
Sardinia minestrone and they'll taste
that and I'll have them what about the
distinction between movement I you know
in in the Blue Zones it's not about you
know vigorous exercise and that you know
the way we think about it treadmills and
gyms and CrossFit and all that kind of
stuff it's just movement you know is
integrated into their daily lives in an
almost unnoticeable way and it's just
continual and perpetual but is there a
distinction when you look at when you
hone in on happiness between people that
are you know sort of active in the sense
that they're walking and of moving their
bodies or you know maybe they work
outdoors or what-have-you
versus you know people that do kind of
have a structured exercise regimen well
people who are getting some sort of
physical activity 60 to 90 minutes a day
are happier more likely to be happy than
people who are are slothful but I'm not
aware of any research that breaks down
intense physical activity and increased
happiness or
happiness and you touched on
volunteerism but I would imagine you
know happiness is very much tied to
service right so people whose lives are
are focused on giving back in my
experience you know happier people and I
know that I'm happier and more fulfilled
and feeling more purposeful when I'm in
the spirit of giving even if that giving
is really in the context of my
professional life that kind of you know
ethos for me translates into a higher
happiness quotient so as there are there
Studies on that or how does that break
down the the best thing I've ever heard
along those lines comes from a Norwegian
Buddhist monk who lives in Minnesota who
says points out that we all have 99
problems we're getting a wrinkle we have
an ache our roof is leaking we have a
dent our car whatever it is and we can
put all of our effort into fixing those
top problems and maybe resolve the top
10 of them but by the time we get those
top 10 off the list there's 10 new ones
at the bottom so it's accepting that
we're always gonna have 99 problems and
putting our focus elsewhere usually on
somebody else's problems or helping
somebody else off and in so doing that
the those 99 problems diminish in size
and and they become less urgent and they
become less salient in our everyday life
so yes volunteering helping others is a
surefire way of making yourself happy
yeah that's a it's a core precept of of
recovery sobriety like 12 step like when
you're when you're not having a good day
like that it's like this is what you're
told like pick up the phone and call
somebody who's having a worse day
through it you know what I mean and then
suddenly your day doesn't seem so bad
it's almost like selfish selflessness
you know what I mean like when you want
to just when you're feeling terrible and
you just want you want to focus on
yourself in your world and your huge
problems if you can just get outside of
yourself and invest yourself in somebody
else's issue your problems seem to
diminish diminish and also the solution
tends to percolate up and seems more
manageable and accessible what was the
thing that in the course of doing this
research and studying these communities
that was most surprising to you or
counter unto it ever what you didn't
expect or just play out the way he
thought it would
well that Singapore was would be so
happy I fully expected his his
Singapore's famous for caning people and
I have more than 14 grams of drugs do
they hang you and and thinking that this
is all propaganda here and getting there
and find out yes that that actually
there's a form of happiness where when
you're the path to success is neatly
laid out for you and you live in the
secure area where it's easy to live out
your values it can indeed produce
happiness and then to go to the other
side of the planet with a diametrically
opposed way of doing things the Danes
are completely free that the laws are
very lacks and a completely different
way of doing things and that's produced
the happiest in a different way happiest
so the the path up the mountain of
happiness they take different faces so
to speak but the summit looks pretty
much the same no matter you know what
route you took are you gonna now set up
a blue zones happiness program that
you're gonna take city to city or are
you gonna incorporate these some of some
of these principles into what you're
already doing you know it's taken me a
decade you know I work with shared care
and we have 200 employees right now and
I'm not about to subset that we are
developing a policy bundle so laws and
codes and policies that municipal
governments can adopt that make it more
likely that their city will be happy so
again we don't tell cities what to do we
show them the policies and and we
helped them pick what's right for them
and then we help them get it passed so
some things it'll make make your city
more likely to be happy
water quality is a huge correlation
between water quality noise as we talked
about before walkability bikeability
programs that help the depressed and
people are anxious there are city
programs that can do that so just making
it clear of what cities can do that will
really favour happiness so we'll just
incorporate it to our current Blue Zones
projects if you if you are able to
petition Congress or let's say you held
some high-ranking appointed position in
the White House what policies on the
federal level would you like to see
changed that could foster you know this
these ideas that you're working on at
the municipal level like what has to
change at the federal career look at the
highest level like what what's fixable
I'm not talking about it you we're not
gonna turn into Singapore but what can
we work on okay so number one if you
can't measure it you can't manage it so
right now we measure the economy we
should have we should be using a gross
national happiness index to measure
because at the end of the day in my
opinion a politician's job is to make us
happy to the greatest amount of
well-being rather than so that should be
the the North Star for all policy and
how we're measuring our presidents in
Congress and the Senate are they making
us happier number two Cameron's
government in in Great Britain he formed
a team 50 people whose job it was to
develop policies most likely to increase
happiness so it has to start with an
evidence base so we should have a sort
of a squad within the federal government
that focuses on well-being and you you
can't ramrod things through Congress it
it requires a conversation and a
consensus and but we have to know what
to do and we have to be able to measure
it and those are the first two steps
and be funding it mm-hmm what what
changes have you made as a result in
your own life I mean you know you're
living in Santa Barbara
you were you were living in Minnesota
you know prior to that like already you
know very blue zones friendly loke
regions locations but did this work kind
of you know inform other changes that
you're thinking about making or have
made or or need to make like what you
know where's the like where where can
you find greater happiness in your own
experience even after doing all of this
stuff yes the journeys always right
right so okay so you're way more likely
to be happy if you're in a committed
relationship so I'm with the lovely and
cruciferous Cathy Freston she is lovely
indeed and she is vegan so I eat a lot
more vegetables it turns out that that
people are eating seven servings of
vegetables that they are happier I know
the importance of sleep so I'm not
Pennywise and pound-foolish when it
comes to my time I get my eight hours of
sleep no matter what I usually don't use
an alarm I know that I'm more likely to
be happy if I'm healthy so it is almost
impossible to get me this to spend a day
without getting some form of physical
activity I like to do I am I love people
and I make it I make time for my friends
I try to socialize six or seven hours I
take a nap you take a nap every day
pretty much do you I'm good at power now
Wow
what time do you wake up in the morning
I wake up after eight hours so if I went
out went deep last night I went to bed
at midnight I woke up at 8:00 right no I
took a little nap before I came over
here actually so yeah it makes a big
difference
drinking a little bit is fine for
happiness drinking a lot is probably
against it so I kind of cut off at eight
or three dream less you're me yes and
and kite sailing that's gonna be the new
thing yeah I'm really
passionate about that it's it's um
knowing your passions and trying them so
I live up in Santa Barbara that has this
the ideal kite sailing conditions in the
country so guys up there doing that but
I don't know that I've ever I don't know
anybody who's done it well you'll know
me I got ya
well maybe you can ro do a field trip I
think you know one of the things that
has been inspiring to me
about you and your example is uh is that
you've accomplished a lot like you've
created these you know incredible works
through the through the books that
you've written and the talks that you've
given and the advocacy that you do and
how you've kind of institutionalized it
for the benefit of these cities you know
that kind of social impact is you know
what I aspire to and you've been a great
mentor and a friend and and you know
I've learned a lot by by getting to know
you and and by just learning from you
know your experience but you're not a
workaholic you know a lot of people who
are who are creating books like you I
mean these are deep dives like this is
deep work these take years and years to
put together and most people that are
involved in that kind of work like
they're they live hermetically and
they're shut-ins and you know because
whatever you know the amount of focus
and intention that that that's required
to produce them is so intense right but
you've you've been able to live these
principles of the blue of the Blue Zones
and create this life for yourself in
which you're able to be as productive as
you are and still maintain this
extraordinary quality of life and that's
like a magic trick to me when I look at
it well I mean in these blue zone areas
that I walked the talk I learned from
them but I do when it when it comes to
work I tend to be like a crack addict
you know I'm on it for right eight hours
a day after take my nap eat my lunch et
cetera get my work out but you
have to put a gun to my head to get me
to work after five o'clock usually cell
there's no upside to being more fanatic
I could have maybe written this book
quicker but I would have had less fun
doing it so I mean thanks for pointing
that out but it's true I put a deep
emphasis in consciousness and unjoin for
the most part enjoying my days with the
right balance of doing something
productive that will yield that life
satisfaction then that pride that I
think is important yeah and it's cool
that that you know your your passion for
adventure you know you used to do these
these crazy expeditions he's bicycle we
talked about it the first time that we
sat down together that that you know the
the work that you do in these books
seems to serve that wanderlust or that's
that that desire to continue you know
continue adventuring well I've been with
National Geographic now for almost 20
years and Peter Miller my great editor
pointed out a long time ago that these
Geographic firsts are kind of passe
right now that if you want to be an
explorer in this day and age you need to
add to the body of knowledge and you
need to educate or illuminate the human
experience and the bike rides were great
experience I think everybody graduated
from a college and university in this
country even a high school should be
required to live abroad for six months
or a year you learn more during those
times than anyplace else and I was able
to do that almost overdrive with eight
years of these let's see in the world
from my bicycle and you develop empathy
you develop a certain amount of wisdom
yeah after all wisdom is knowledge plus
experience and maybe I didn't get the
most knowledge in the world doing this
but I got a ton of experience so that
kind of adds to the wisdom and it gives
you a lot of quiet time to think you
know I'm sure you probably get your best
thinking done when you're you know doing
a marathon across live or Swedish
archipelago I don't know how much
thinking I was doing I was thinking
about when I was gonna be over general I
got a daily basis yeah I'll bet you find
your running Barry
of course meditative and you probably
get a lot of good idea
is doing this and and and and so the the
the the expeditions leading up to what
I'm doing now was part of that David
just rode his bike across David who's
filming over here he just used rode his
bike across Australia okay yeah I knew
yeah I loved him
not just because he's from Malta and
he's got a lot of hair he has excellent
hair he does but yeah but then then you
know maturing those adventures to then
you know mind the human spirit and
extract from it you know ideas that can
be beneficial to others like that's the
National Geographic like mission right
more mortis yeah yes they're finding the
that's the only way they can be relevant
they can't keep covering summits of
Everest er right you know make it to the
North Pole which is gonna disappear in a
few years anyway speaking of which Blue
Zones of happiness is a cover story for
Nat Geo is that the October issue as I
said November issue member you know in
October yeah that's exciting man I'm
very psyched that was David's
photographs
well actually it's Corey Richard
photographs different photographer but
when there was actually two
photographers working on it and we
worked it took 14 months to recover and
shoot that story a photographer's super
hard workers they they made at least two
trips to each of these blue zones of
happiness to cover it right and and
what's the difference between the book
and what's gonna be in the piece so the
piece just focuses on the happiest
places and the book is more about how to
take what we learned in these places and
put it to work in your life I offers a
blueprint for changing your personal
environment six different facets of your
personal environment to make it more
likely you'll be happy and then it
marshals in this science so we know what
really works for happiness and what
doesn't it's exciting man October third
it comes out and you're gonna be doing
like a residency on The Today Show can
you talk about that yeah yes
four days in The Today Show it probably
already have passed but it's a it's
October 9th 10th 11 now put this up
before that and is that going to be you
in studio at the Today Show with filmed
stuff that you that took place in these
communities or how's that gonna go
it's know I've traveled to all of the
Blue Zones areas with the Today Show I
see and stuffs in the can already yes
and but then I'm going to New York to be
honest and they're right yeah marshaled
in but no I work with cynthia mcfadden
there and a very gifted producer named
Jake Whitman and the three we've done a
number of stories with the Blue Zones
the longevity and know we're doing
happiness together and it's a great
little team to work with it's gonna be
amazing that are you excited
do you like that a publicity marketing
side of all this kind of stuff being the
forward it's not really I can do it I
can do it but no I'm from the Midwest
and that the talk tree gets chopped off
in the Midwest but you know as an author
you have to sing for your supper or you
don't eat I enjoy talking with you this
is probably the most fun I have actually
James a most charming man on the planet
I have a reporter I just I just report
the facts
October 3rd so that's so it's October
9th and that and then four days on that
that week right yes yeah it's cool man
and what's what's beyond that what's
next what's getting you excited well
I'll just state for a while um I'm I
want to focus on the art of life for a
while and I've spend a lot of time
developing this happiness idea and the
Blue Zones idea and now I want to create
a new application and focus on the art
of life and like what how do you
optimize this experience we're all given
the ink use of this great this great
story that a guy gets to heaven and he
he said he's he said okay what do we do
now when we're up here
and God said you were just in heaven and
you screwed it up you know I mean this
life it's I think if you really think
about it and try there's so much more to
be made of of our experiences here and
my research shapes the decisions I make
but now I need I need to customize that
general knowledge into a personal
prescriptive so well I think you deserve
it man yeah at least for a month yeah
good talking you likewise rich yeah man
oh my god
anything else you wanna say no that yeah
well I will say you know when I first
met you and I did this podcast that you
know I it was just fun rapping with you
but I speak all over the country I
cannot tell you how it you know I've
done TED talks and Oprah more people
come up to me and say oh I heard you on
the rich roll podcast and it's like an
instant membership into the club of cool
so thank you I appreciate that
you know all the right things to say
alright super fun man and I look forward
to doing more of these with you in the
meantime
everybody pick up the Blue Zones of
happiness I'm sure you're gonna be
seeing a lot of this book it's going to
be in our atmosphere everywhere you look
you can catch down on The Today Show on
those appointed dates and you can find
him on the Internet at is it at Dan
Buettner or at Blue Zones
F Blues at Blue Zones on Twitter right
and you're on Instagram as well at Blue
Zone Center Lou's own stones calm for
all your Blue Zones needs edification
all right awesome man thanks so much
thank you peace and plants
[Music]
you